hey guys it's justed and today we're
going to be talking about the new
fitness plus service that just launched
by apple this is something that they've
been talking about for a while and it is
now officially here and it is out so
basically if you have an apple watch
you'll be able to have access to the
service
if you recently bought an apple watch
you can get three month free
subscription i'm so excited about the
service because right now more than ever
people are looking for ways to stay
active especially when we're being told
to stay in our homes we can't go to gyms
and we can't kind of resume the daily
activities that we normally were doing
before the whole world basically shut
down so here we have apple fitness
all set up i have it on my ipad i also
have it on
my iphone here so if you guys check this
out the
fitness app will now transform in the
latest update
you'll be able to see all of your
activity but then this little middle
button that will bring you to
the apple fitness app if you've ever
used any type of online fitness service
this is very similar to that but what
they have done is really outfitted this
incredible studio so all of these
classes are so incredible
so high quality and one of the coolest
things is it does integrate with apple
music so you're able to see all of the
playlists and then you can save those
playlists if you enjoy the music so you
can listen to it later
so not only are you able to use your
iphone or your ipad
but it is also accessible on apple tv
you just
bring your apple watch close to the
television it'll automatically detect
who you are
and you'll be able to start training
right away you can go and use someone
else's apple tv so if you're
at home with your family or a friend's
house you can just get close to their
apple tv
it'll automatically detect log you in
using all of your settings
even if they're not a fitness plus
subscriber you'll still be able to work
out
and have all of the data and stats
synced to your account you can filter
all of the classes by the type of class
that you want
hit yoga strength
dance you better believe i'm going to
take a dance class
one of the things that they're really
stressing is there are so many workouts
here that you can do if you're a
beginner if you've never done any type
of activity they actually have an
entire beginner playlist so you can just
add all of those classes
and take all of those one by one and
then from there you can progress on
in your fitness journey so one of the
cool things about apple fitness plus is
they have so many different classes and
if you do
have some equipment at home like a rower
or a bike or a treadmill you can also
integrate that
in to your apple fitness workout now i
do have a peloton so i've been doing
peloton for the past
i guess almost two years at this point
so it's really exciting to kind of get
some new trainers and to start doing
some new treadmill workouts so we are
about ready to go
treadmill with scott 10 minutes let's do
it
[Music]
the focus of this workout is to really
push yourself on the four all-out speed
intervals
use the recoveries to help you push
harder we only have
10 minutes let's get right to work
it's also really cool because they are
taking into account some hearing
impaired people that might be doing this
and they have learned all of their
intros so that people will be able to
know when to actually start
so cool let's go
there it is there's the barn bar i'm at
the front of the pack
i love that they put up a nice little
countdown
so you're really knowing when you can
stop doing an activity
that's great
that was really fun it's cool because it
shows me all of my stats
shows me the class that i did and if i
want to go into a mindful cooldown
i can just hop into one of those classes
right away i'm out of breath
i like that the activity summary has a
thumbnail of the class that you just
took
so your friends will actually be seeing
the same result on their apple watch
they'll be able to see the class that
you took
and if they want to do the same one they
can just click into it and take it as
well so far my favorite thing is how
well this integrates with the apple
watch you're able to have your heart
rate data
always on screen and when they call
attention to your heart rate whether you
want it to be lower or if you're
starting a cool down that is the only
thing that will pop up on the screen so
you're not distracted by any other
metrics
it's just what the instructor is talking
about i also love that up in the top
right corner
is your activity rings so you're able to
see how much further you have to go for
the rest of the day
to continue to close your rings another
thing that i love is the burn bar
this is really neat because it allows
you to see where you're at with other
people that have taken this class
you do have the option of turning the
burn bar off if you don't want to feel
competitive and you just want to relax
and work out at your own pace most of my
running records or goals that i've
achieved is because of the leaderboard i
will see that somebody is in front of me
and i just have to push a little bit
harder to get past them
but a lot of times most of the goals
that i'm looking to achieve are to be
better than myself so that's always the
most exciting thing is to see that
progress and to see that you're actually
making change
let's do a strength workout this time
i'm going to choose my class
by what i want to listen to so i would
like to do
10 minute workout and what about
pure dance what do you got for me
strength with greg all right strength
with greg here we go
starting it on the watch
hey what's up greg here at the physics
plus studio in beautiful santa monica
california
santa monica squat down
sit down start to explore
oh man we did it
one of the things that i noticed that i
really like is they have two other
people in the studio and each person is
doing
a variety of different types of
modifications
so if the main instructor is doing
something that's too difficult they have
an easier modification so if you have an
injury
or if you're not at the level of the
main instructor
there's a wide variety of options i just
really like
that it gives you this really nice panel
that shows you everything that you did
your average heart rate your total
calories your active calories
and your total time and it shows you
your activity rings feel like we now
need to go test this out on the apple tv
[Music]
i'll be doing a modification of this
love a good modification
so for this one i did some modifications
so i'm kind of in the middle of the pack
i didn't work
to the hardest of my abilities but i
kept it kind of very center so this is
kind of cool because it does give you
that nice range
not gonna lie working out on this
massive tv was a really
cool experience another thing that's
awesome is if you happen to go to
somebody's house who has an apple tv
and they might not have a fitness plus
subscription all you need to do
is get your apple watch close to it and
then you can connect your apple watch
and you can do all of your classes and
all of your data will be synced to your
account
so this is awesome i'm exhausted from
all this working out that i've been
doing today i feel like a nice yoga
session or a nice mindful cool down
is an order let me grab the ipad and go
outside
welcome to my practice i'm going to
practice practicing practicing
practicing i'd like to do a 10 minute
yoga class today
so i'm going to go into the filter let's
click 10 minutes
and some chill vibes let's see how this
music looks
oh yeah khalid's in the playlist khalid
was my top played artist
of 2020. i'm so glad to have some new
yoga workouts because before
the whole pandemic thing happened i used
to go to yoga at like six o'clock in the
morning every single day
and now i haven't really been practicing
as much as i used to
so let's uh let's do this
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you for joining me sharing your
time and energy
stay active close your rings see you
next time
it was my first yoga class wow
awesome the thing that i love the most
about this is they have so many classes
that are like
10 20 minutes so if you just have time
to do something very quick or very
simple
like you can just go do this before you
even start your day
i feel very relaxed now i'm gonna take
all of my items back inside and
i'd like to look at my stats for the day
and check out what i accomplished
i did a lot of working out in 10 minute
increments today
i'm exhausted so i'm back from my first
day working out with fitness plus and
i'm so excited to see what some of my
data looks like from the day
now i didn't do that many intensive
workouts for the sake of
just making this video i do plan on
sharing some more of my results on
twitter and instagram so be sure to
follow me at ijustine
so let's take a look at what we did
today
when you go into the fitness app you're
greeted with your entire summary of
everything that you did i have not quite
met my move goal of burning 500 calories
yet so when i click into a workout it'll
show you
everything that you did and i also love
that it does integrate so well with the
apple watch so you're able to see all of
your heart rate data right there
so i managed to run a mile shows your
average heart rate
your average pace and where you are on
the burn bar oh my heart rate recovery
as well
this is a class that i did last night
that was actually a little bit more of a
workout so i did three miles in 30
minutes
and i had to pause right there to go get
a camera because
after halfway through i was like wait a
minute i should be filming this so i
paused the workout
and then picked it up and continued on
so the account that i'm using right now
is not my actual personal account so
this is just one for the sake of testing
this so this is not
representative of all of my awards
i'm obsessed yeah i don't mess around
when it comes to awards also some of my
competitions
i really love the apple watch i really
love having all of this information all
of this data
basically in the palm of my hand i'm
able to take my heart rate
i'm able to now test my blood oxygen
level and i'm able to track all of my
progress especially since i started
running earlier this year it's been
really cool to be able to see those
changes
not only in my pace but in my heart rate
so i'd say my first impressions of the
classes they're really
really good i love that the trainers
focus on fitness they basically are
there
to show you the way to do things in
other fitness classes they tend to talk
a lot about
other things and they sometimes forget
that they're teaching a fitness class
and it kind of drives me crazy because
i'm like okay
you need to be focusing on making sure
that you're verbally telling us the
things that we need to do if we're not
actually looking
not telling us about the party that you
went to last weekend and another thing
that i like is that they integrated all
of the trainers
in all of the classes so you'll see some
of the trainers from the yoga classes to
the strength to the hit to the dance
workouts all training and working
together
and it kind of makes it feel like a
really collaborative fun
team-based experience this is so cool
scott isn't here he's not even on the
treadmill anymore
that's awesome that all of the trainers
kind of train with each other in all of
the classes
so far i'm very impressed and i'm
looking forward to seeing what other
people think of the service
i think fitness is such an important
part of people's lives and if it isn't
something that is important in your life
right now
i highly encourage you to maybe consider
somehow getting involved in some sort of
activity even if it's just walking
5 10 15 20 minutes a day add on a little
bit of time each day
and you'd be surprised how much better
it can make you feel i appreciate you
guys taking the time watching this video
and i hope that if you do try out apple
fitness that you will enjoy it as much
as i did
and hopefully you'll find some trainers
that you resonate with and will help you
meet your fitness goals in the meantime
i am gonna go eat dinner
because i'm exhausted from all of my
working out
[Music]